bonsoir et bienvenue pour le 7-8 lecture
le journal de la rédaction tout de suite
les titres de ce 5 juin la réforme de
l'aide juridictionnelle fait débats les
avocats étaient mobilisés pour réclamer
au gouvernement des mesures sur le
financement elle les commémorations du
débarquement vont bientôt débuter
témoignage dans cette édition auprès de
l'association mémoire de trappes
souvenir de la seconde guerre mondiale
le nouveau maire de maurepas à grégory
deir estia invité du journal après avoir
récupéré pour l'ump la commune détenue
par la gauche depuis trente ans et la
firme de nouvelles prises de position
comme ce rejet de la réforme des rythmes
scolaires dont nous parlerons tout à
l'heure
l'image du jour c'est la victoire du
collège gustave-courbet de trappes dans
le tournoi d'improvisation de déclic
théâtre sur la scène du scarabée à la
verrière hier soir et après plusieurs
heures de match et les jeunes trappistes
se sont imposés face à ceux des
l'encours est de magny les hameaux
le tournoi d'impôt intercollèges qui
fêtait sa neuvième édition une édition
une fois de plus intégralement filmées
par les équipes de téléphiles ce sera à
découvrir très prochainement sur notre
antenne en attendant voici les réactions
des vainqueurs de cette année propos
recueillis par elodie moi tu avais un
peu de pression mais le coach nous avait
dit que que voilà il faut pas se prendre
la tête faut se lâcher sur le terrain
pour s'amuser et c'est comme ça qu'on
fait des bonnes appréciations faire
comme si public était pas là et voilà au
final oui c'est la première fois et
sociaux à première année un bon cru un
bon à mon niveau et c'est toujours
agréable de voir les joueurs qui se
révèle vraiment en match et notamment en
finale et en demi finales puisque
l'échéance approchant les avocats
français étaient appelés ce jeudi à
participer à une journée d'action
nationale pour obtenir une
revalorisation de l'aide
juridictionnelle une indemnités allouées
par l'état à la profession pour défendre
les clients les plus démunis la
mobilisation s'est faite également du
côté de versailles hall 1 13 et patrick
jacques de dixmude
les avocats crient leur ras-le-bol ce
matin le barreau de versailles s'est
engagé auprès de ce mouvement de grève
national l'objet de leur colère
l'absence de propositions la
chancellerie sur la réforme du système
de la durée dictionnaire ils demandent
notamment plus de budget pour cette aide
très utile à de nombreux justiciables
elle permet en effet aux plus démunis
d'avoir tout de même recours à un avocat
rémunérés selon un barème
ce barème est extrêmement faible on
considère qu'il ne s'agit pas réellement
d'une rémunération mais bien plutôt
d'une indemnisation car en général les
dossiers sont entre guillemets
déficitaire ces dossiers nécessitant
peut-être plus de temps que les autres
plus de choix plus d'attention pour une
rémunération qui est sans aucun rapport
avec les diplômes des avocats qui
consentent à exercer études
internationales
le temps passe etc etc ce matin une
délégation a déposé une motion de
protestation auprès du directeur de
cabinet du préfet une rencontre d'une
dizaine de minutes et l'espoir d'avoir
fait bouger les choses on assure que
c'est de lui faire comprendre qu'il y
avait un vrai ras-le-bol la profession
d'avocat et je voulais rappeler que
c'était la première fois de ma vie que
je portais une robe dans un lieu
administratif et que si on faisait c'est
que vraiment on était arrivé à la limite
de la limite
le barreau de versailles a émis ses
propositions sur un financement
notamment celle de taxer les actes
juridiques
on sait que la situation de son pays
fait que l'époux budget ne peut pas
faire peut-être grand chose mais il ya
un financement complémentaire qui est
d'instaurer une taxe sur les actes
juridiques qui permettraient de
récupérer une somme d'environ 300
millions d'euros
avec 300 millions d'euros ça permet
d'avoir un budget suffisant pour faire
fonctionner toutes les missions comme
eux de nombreux barreaux se sont
mobilisés dans toute la france il espère
une réponse dans les plus brefs délais
sans quoi le mouvement de grève pourrait
s'amplifier et c'est dans ce contexte
qu'a lieu la présentation de médine
mouche l'auteur présumé de la tuerie du
musée juif de bruxelles est la bienvenue
à versailles il s'est exprimé pour la
première fois en public depuis son
arrestation il a simplement contesté sa
remise à la belgique l'audience était
renvoyée au 12 juin à la demande de sa
défense médine mouche qui reste donc
incarcéré pour l'instant à la maison
d'arrêt de bois d'arcy invités de ce 5
juin grégory est resté bonsoir bonsoir
on va parler de vos deux premiers mois
en tant que maire
ump de maurepas vous avez fait basculer
cette commune ont créé à gauche depuis
1989 mais avant toute chose comment se
porte votre adjoint à l'environnement
christian guyot il a été agressé au
bassin de la courance la semaine
dernière par un membre de la communauté
du voyage
absolument je le regrette mais il va
beaucoup mieux ils sont rien
d'inquiétant côté l'allemand s'était
effectivement les robustes de la presse
mais tout va mieux l'auteur des coups je
le précise à tous même été placé en
garde à vue un pour finir sur cette
affaire on va parler de vos actions en
tant que maire quel bilan vous faites de
ces deux premiers mois ce que les
principaux dossiers sont lancés est-ce
que vous avez terminé les audits de la
précédente équipe
pas encore pas encore le chantier est
lourd là nous sommes en train de mettre
en place tous nos projets nous avons
déjà voté le budget 2014 il y a quelques
jours et donc là nous nous réunissons
souvent en séminaire pour organiser les
projets que nous allons établir sur
toute la mandature ça prend du temps il
faut vous savez quand vous arrêtez d'une
gestion qui a existé pendant 25 ans il
faut déjà faire un état des lieux et
comprendre le fonctionnement et la tâche
est lourde
je découvre un certain nombre de
dossiers jean débloquer beaucoup
selon mes engagements de campagne que je
tiens et donc de ce fait on agit avec
recul sans précipitation mais avec
responsabilité
vous parlez du budget qui a été voté un
budget stable la documentation d'impôt
allant conomie sont à faire aucune
augmentation d'impôts comme je m'y étais
engagé avec mon équipe nous avons réduit
de 5 % le budget global de
fonctionnement parce que nous avons
hérité d'une gestion extrêmement
étroites une explosion de la masse
salariale de plus de 600000 euros
nous avons une baisse de la dotation
globale de fonctionnement de 270000
euros
et donc ce qui fait que nos marges de
manoeuvre sont très restreintes et que
nous avons dû faire des efforts de
gestion pour préserver le pouvoir
d'achat des morlaisiens ça se traduit
comment ces efforts de gestion ont
bloqué les salaires des gens qui
travaillent au possible
ces 5 %
de baisse de dépenses de fonctionnement
dans tous les services c'est le non
remplacement d'un fonctionnaire qui par
la retraite et c'est la réorganisation
également de certains services pour être
plus efficace est également plus
performant pour les services publics et
dans les services publics ira reprendre
quelques-uns de vos points de programme
vous nous dites rapidement 6 effet si
c'est pas encore fait aussi cet encours
révision du plan local d'urbanisme
alors je n'ai jamais dit que j'allais le
réviser j'ai stoppé des projets liés
bloquer certains pour alimenter une
carte du village
absolument ça a été ok cette ces faits
et a également à la meinl où j'ai bloqué
la construction d'un immeuble de six
étages investissements pour la
rénovation des écoles
c'est en cours en fait nous avons décidé
que le budget 2014 serait obligé de
transition étant donné que nous avons eu
très peu de temps quand même pour le
boucler à peine dix jours et que nous
avons décidé de faire un plan
d'investissement pluriannuel sur
l'ensemble de la mandature pour rénover
l'ensemble de nos structures les écoles
en font partie comme les gymnases tout
ce qui affaiblit aux sports sur le
développement du numérique dans les
écoles s'est fait en corse est en crise
et en gagne c'est en cours et les
développements numériques dans les
écoles mais également au sein de la
collectivité parce que je découvre quand
même certains services qui fonctionne
encore avec des factures à la main ou cd
agents qui travaillent sur des postes
qui ont plus de 14 ans donc en termes
d'informatique il ya énormément de
travail à faire
augmentation des agents de la police
municipale notamment pour la nuit
alors la brigade de nuit non pas encore
nous sommes en pleine réflexion
en revanche nous allons
nous recrutons en interne avec les
forces vives déjà existantes au sein de
la collectivité parce que nous avons
tous les talents nous recrutons des
agents de la voie publique
c'est une création d'une brigade anti
graffiti c'est fait ça c'est fait il en
est question création d'un conseil des
aînés pour les associer aux décisions ça
faisait partie de cet encours nous
allons lancer le chantier cette année
nous sommes allés dans votre ville afin
de recueillir le sentiment de la
population ce qui a changé déjà
peut-être est-ce palpable dans les rues
de la commune de maurepas voici la
réponse que je vois le temps devant moi
accord à titre personnel je te
recommande aux rythmes scolaires
je suis pas trop courant de ce qu'ils
changent mais déjà je suis contente que
la ferme de manque pas là soient
conservés alors là j'en ai aucune idée
et jusqu'à maintenant j'ai rien vu on
marque et ses nouveaux seins j'ai vu
qu'il y avait des affiches sur le le
rythme scolaire je n'ai pas vu de
changement très perceptible j'ai reçu un
avis dans la boîte aux lettres
concernant les écoles mais
j'ai pas je n'ai pas remarqué d'autres
changements dans la vie rien de concret
qua non non non non non c'est peut-être
un petit peu trop tôt sinon parce que ce
matin un avis sur le nouveau rythme
scolaire et ses récents quand même donc
je pense qu'il va pas révolutionner mort
fois en deux mois
est ce que vous allez révolutionner
maurepas ont deux mois c'est court vous
êtes attendus sur des changements les
gens avaient alors déjà sur l'entretien
de la collectivité j'avais un axe fort
quand même c'était ville propre et avec
la brigade anti graffiti que nous avons
mis en place nous avons effacé un
certain nombre de dégradations
et puis là on nettoie absolument la
collectivité comme ça devait être fait
normalement de les années passées et les
rythmes scolaires aussi ses revenus dans
le micro trottoir et qui va s'y attarder
juste une question concernant l'espace
albert camus ce centre culturel cette
salle de spectacle quel avenir
vous avez réduit les budgets bloquer le
développement de la salle nous avons
suspendu la saison professionnelle mais
nous avons maintenu la saison
associative que nous souhaitons
renforcer parce que nous souhaitons une
politique culturelle plus proche des
norvégiens c'est à dire vous allez
couper les spectacles qui auront moins
de spectacles proposés ça permet de
faire des vagues le doubs où il y aura
autant de spectacles sauf que cet accès
vers le milieu associatif qui est très
riche à maurepas et donc nous souhaitons
les faire exister les faire vivre
sur l'aspect professionnel le contrat
n'est pas encore signé pour ce qui
allait se produire les contrats et ce
n'est pas encore signé donc là où nous
on se laisse le temps vous avez des
nouvelles équipes donc nouvelles
ambitions
on se laisse le temps de réfléchir une
nouvelle politique les équipes qui sont
en place dans cet espace albert camus au
sein de la municipalité
certaines vont être transférés dans
d'autres structures voilà on a des
talents dans tous les services et on
aura besoin de tout le monde
le dossier qui vous occupe en ce moment
comme dans beaucoup de communes c'est
solide et un rythme scolaire alors
pourquoi vous y opposez pourquoi ne pas
suivre ce qui avait été envisagé par
l'ancienne équipe vous êtes revenu sur
le rôle des engagements absolument
j'entendais les mots repas bien dans
votre reportage oui je distribue en ce
moment une lettre du maire à tous les
mauriciens pour expliquer mon choix
alors sachez que conseil municipal le 3
juin j'ai fait voter une délibération
qui portait sur un voeu du report de
cette réforme d'un an
g j'ai obtenu 29 voix sur 33 une partie
de l'opposition s'est même joint à se
veut donc ce qui prouve que
ce n'est pas une décision idéologique
mais qui est centrée vraiment sur
l'intérêt de l'enfant et je m'y oppose
parce que premièrement nous n'avons pas
les moyens financiers d'appliquer cette
réforme de la dotation de l'état
même si l'état versera 50 euros à 50
euros alors que l'amour passé 200 euros
par enfant donc il faut que la
collectivité qu'on pense et comment
fait-on pour compenser il faut augmenter
les impôts et je refuse d'augmenter les
impôts des mauriciens vous avez le
soutien des gilet jaune cette
association de parents d'élèves on a vu
quelques images lors du conseil
municipal et qui vient de se tenir la
ville ne proposera donc pas d'activités
périscolaires à la rentrée non nous
avons demandé un report de cette réforme
et demandé au gouvernement qu'il donne
les moyens financiers pour appliquer
correctement cette réforme parce que je
le répète il y a quand même une baisse
qualitative de l'offre pédagogique dans
le sens où les villes riches pour
proposer quelque chose d'adapté et de
confortables avec des contenus innovants
pour aider les enfants réussir alors que
les villes les plus pauvres ne pourront
pas le faire et c'est ça qui est
dramatique le gouvernement le
responsable de l'académie aussi qui dit
que de toute façon ça se fera même si
les communes ne veulent pas l'appliquer
ils fixeront les horaires si les maires
ne veulent pas les appliquer ce sera la
préfecture d'intervenir d'abord je sers
est engagé je ne sais pas comment ils
vont faire et qui nous donne les moyens
et qu'est ce qu'ils vont dire aussi un
peu à tous les maires de france ils
refusent d'appliquer cette réforme et
qui n'ont pas les moyens
il ya une petite surprise imposent les
oreilles à sonder les écoles doivent
être ouvertes de telle heure à telle
heure une fois que leur sera terminé
s'il n'y a pas d'activités périscolaires
si ya pas de gare de proposer pour les
enfants que vont devenir les enfants à
la sortie
naturellement nous sommes responsables
si toutefois nous allons en arriver là
nous proposions une mise en place a
minima
pour accueillir les enfants mais de
toute façon l'esprit de la réforme ne
serait pas respectée il n'est pas
respectée on le voit d'ailleurs dans la
ville de trappes à côté où ça se passe
très très mal le mercredi matin les
écoles ne seront pas ouvertes vous
désirez pas si on vous impose d'ouvrir
les écoles le mercredi matin à banias
pour haïr bakou puisque l'on parle de
cette réforme sachez que du côté des
longs cours le merci oppose également
l'opposition socialiste interpelle le
maire de montre qu'un projet soit
élaborée il évoque une proposition qui
aurait été fait avec aucune activité
périscolaire notamment à l'école du
berceau rejetée par les parents les
enseignants
la section locale du parti socialiste
qui demande à jean michel fourgous ce
qu'il fera de cette subvention à 250000
euros qui sera versée quoi qu'il arrive
à l'état je vous ai posé la question
tout à l'heure cette subvention vous
dans votre commune que vous allez
toucher vous allez en faire quoi
parce qu'elle sera versée cette
subvention puisque la réforme va
s'appliquer moi je ne sais pas encore si
elle sera versée étant donné que nous
allons pas appliquer ce décret nous
verrons le moment venu
mais je le répète c'est une aberration
économique familiale éducative au
détriment du bien-être de l'enfant et
c'est pour ça que nous demandons un
report et une pérennisation des moyens
financiers pour appliquer de manière
qualitative
c'est très forme oui il faut améliorer
et faire réussir nos enfants mais il
faut à ce moment là que l'état nous
accompagnent et ce n'est pas le cas
actuellement mais je reviens sur l'école
le mercredi matin qui vous n'ouvrez pas
à vous dit il n'y aura pas d'école vous
n'appliquerait pas cette réforme et
avoir une difficulté pour les
enseignants les enseignants leur
responsable hiérarchique l'inspection
académique va leur dire vous devez
dispenser les cours
rendez-vous dans les écoles mais qu'il
donne les moyens les écoles seront
fermées mais qui lui est qu'il donne les
moyens nécessaire de le faire je n'ai
pas recruté d'animateurs également pour
animer les activités périscolaires
comment on va faire l'état c'est une
question comment va faire l'état
nous n'avons pas les moyens d'appliquer
cette réforme
le bras de fer se poursuit absolument
déjà nous l'actualité de ces derniers
jours a aussi été marquée par les
annonces autour de la réforme
territoriale du président françois
hollande au delà du remaniement des
régions l'ile-de-france
elle n'est pas concernée vous le savez
il ya aussi la question de la
disparition des départements du
renforcement des intercommunalités
également est ce que vous êtes inquiet
pour l'avenir de votre commune pour les
responsabilités supplémentaires qui
pourraient vous arrivez sur les
disparitions du département sur les
intercoms plus grosse aussi je ne suis
pas inquiet vous avez mangé un
réformiste par nature sauf que quand on
veut réformer il faut le faire avec tous
les partenaires
alors que là le gouvernement nous impose
une réforme
il n'y a pas eu de discussion de
discussion possible et donc de ce fait
nous sommes quand même inquiet de des
compétences qui vont transférer mais je
pense que ça peut être positif mais il
faut faire les choses avec les
collectivités et non contre elle
pour l'instant aucune concertation vous
n'avez pas été sollicités absolument pas
franchement peut-être sur le
rapprochement avec saint quentin en
yvelines la communauté d'agglomération
on en avait parlé pendant la campagne
des municipales pour l'instant maurepas
est rattachée à la communauté de
communes des étangs où vous en êtes le
premier vice président chez vous
souhaitez changer vous rapprocher de la
communauté
alors j'ai 50 ans j'ai toujours dis donc
pendant ma campagne que je consulterai
les mortuaciens pour proposer l'avenir
de l'intercommunalité
il faut savoir que le préfet de région
va proposer un futur schéma
intercommunal au 1er septembre et que la
carte intercommunale devra être achevé
au 1er janvier 2016
donc j'ai cru comprendre ce que j'ai une
rhino que le préfet il ya quelques jours
que maurepas à coignières plaisir
villepreux et les claies plus une partie
de la haute vallée de chevreuse allait
rejoindre la communauté d'agglomération
de saint quentin
si toutefois cela devait se faire c'est
sous conditions il faut pas que ce soit
une augmentation non plus fiscale de la
fiscalité auprès des morlaisiens et il
faut qu'on discute également des
transferts de compétences et de ce que
ça va apporter au quotidien dément pas
bien c'est ça l'essentiel le fond dans
vous allez faire une consultation un
référendum sur la commune un référendum
ou une réunion publique déjà ou une
consultation numérique
on en n'est pas là pour le moment mais
en tout cas je consulterai les moyens
parce que il est important qu'ils se
saisissent de l'avenir de leur commune
on quitte un peu l'actualité locale on
se penche sur le national vous êtes un
militant ump depuis très longtemps
depuis l'adolescence
aujourd'hui la moitié de votre vie qui
aimerait tant que militant ump
aujourd'hui en tant qu'adhérent quel
regard vous avez sur la situation à la
tête du parti
cette affaire avec elle jean françois
copé obligé de démissionner sur fond
d'affaires de fausses factures de
surfacturation pour la campagne de
nicolas sarkozy lors de la
présidentielle
c'est difficile pour votre famille
politique qui se divisent ou situés au
bas écouter oui c'est difficile mais je
fais le parallèle aussi avec moi même me
mords pas où j'ai quand même été élu sur
le renouveau et je pense que c'est aussi
nécessaire à l'ump je pense que les
français attendent qu'on fasse de la
politique autrement et qu'on arrête avec
toutes ces affaires qui polluent la
gauche la droite tous les partis
politiques en france et donc en effet
l'ump un gros travail à faire et surtout
de se repenser
niveau de sa ligne politique et c'est
l'objet du congrès qu'il irait au mois
d'octobre vous situez où vous sur cette
ligne politique plutôt une ouverture
vers vers lui des ihu vers le centre ou
alors comme le henry guaino vous ne
voulez pas d'ouverture vers le centre
est une réaffirmation vraiment
clairement à droite
moi je veux une réelle information de ce
qui était de les valeurs de l'ump est sa
création en 2002 s'était dit avec les
libéraux les gaullistes et les
centristes
il faut en discuter je suis pas persuadé
qu'une alliance une fusion avec le
centre soit une bonne solution et qui
pour incarner même percé d'une bonne
question c'est forcément il ya un tir au
but manqué c'est vrai j'attends de voir
les candidats mais c'est vrai que mon
préféré comme nicolas sarkozy à maurepas
l'ump a terminé en tête lors des
élections européennes le fonds national
est à 16% malgré tout il n'y avait pas
de candidat front national lors des
élections municipales
est-ce que vous ça vous inquiète est-ce
que c'est pas propre à cette commune
elle demeure pas puisque dans toutes les
communes le front national a fortement
progressé mais ce que vous pensez qu'il
ya un ancrage qui se fait dans la
commune non parce que je pense que c'est
en fonction de l'actualité et puis du
ras le bol des français
je suis quand même très satisfait que
l'ump souhaite arriver en tête et
largement
alors que certaines communes communes le
fn qui est arrivé en tête
le fn est largement derrière sa commune
quand même rap sur 50 ans on a
absolument raison que je suis satisfait
que meurent par est une ville modéré
mais il ya quand même un ras-le-bol a
été exprimée il faut là où il faut
l'entendre dans un instant nous avons
parlé dans ce journal des commémorations
du 6 juin dudit des les 70 ans du
débarquement
vous allez fêter dans votre commune de
débarquement où vous allez fêter
rapprochement certaine manière oui on a
absolument rien on a une visite des
allemands dans le cadre de notre
jumelage la semaine dernière ça s'est
très très bien passé j'ai été accueillie
avec le comité de jumelage et la
municipalité
et puis pour le débarquement nous on va
pas le fêter mais on va faire l'appel du
18 juin avec la ville de cognac merci la
ligue 1 merci les manques pas invité ce
soir du journal de mois et demi après le
début de votre mandature merci à vous
merci nous sommes donc à la veille du
70e anniversaire
du débarquement des alliés des
commémorations se prépare vous le savez
et chacun de son côté dans sa famille se
souvient parfois le collectif mémoire de
trappes nous a permis de recueillir de
témoignages sur la situation pendant la
guerre dans cette commune mathilde
capbern et jonathan vilma locomotive à
l'entrée de frapper le triage ils
étaient à la sortie par josette de
manille à 5 ans lorsque la france
capitule face à l'allemagne
c'était en 1940 les troupes allemandes
occupent une grande partie du territoire
lors du premier bombardement de trappes
elle est à l'école les sirènes
retentissent des maisons brûlent les
souvenirs restent intactes j'étais en
garde chez la mère de mon parrain juste
à côté de chez nous et ils ont commencé
à l'interroger
c'était il avait les grands en truc noir
en série noire et puis il y avait trois
allemands comme les épuise commencé à
les interroger
et puis j'étais avec elle me serrait la
main chez vue ils cassent et où il
déchire et les photos il la menaçait
c'est à ce moment là que maman est
arrivée et qui l'on demandait son
identité tout ils ont dit bah ça tombe
bien parce que on va chez vous mais là
ils l'ont insulté en me disant mais vous
aviez abandonner votre fille enfin bref
on élit robin âgé de 12 ans en 1940 nous
raconte ses souvenirs d'écolier il vit à
trappes
mais il est scolarisé à versailles on
directeur des colonnes me frémit à
versailles
11 novembre 41 il avait mis au tableau
pas de manifestation publique mais un
souvenir dans le coeur je peux vous dire
que l époque allemande écrire ça c'était
quand même prendre de gros risques en 44
c'était pour moi une année
disons assez importante c'était là le 6
juin 44 j'ai passé mon cap2 dessinateur
de conclure des débarquements mais ce
qu'il voulait dire que antérieurement
fallait pas manquer les cours ou alors
on rate et ou quoi 1944 une année
importante pour rayer cinq jours avant
d'obtenir son diplôme
la ville est bombardée par les alliés
une bonne soufflante tombe sur la maison
de ses parents
la maison d'habitation ça c'est
l'aventuré vert
à cette époque
70% des trappistes sont des cheminots
les actes de résistance de sabotage sont
de plus en plus nombreux pour josette et
elie tous deux filles et fils de
cheminot leur père deviennent à leur
manière des résistants il était un peu
impliqués dans des choses qu'il fallait
pas et je me souviens très bien qu'on
faisait avec les journaux et les
affiches les tracts on faisait des
boules de papier qu'on faisait trempé et
puis après on oublie ça dans la
gazinière
mon père a fait je dirais un peu de
résistance comme il était électricien il
avait le droit de sortir le jour la nuit
il avait un papier pour moi il en quoi
c'est lui qui portait les papiers de
l'un à l'autre des goûts il l'a fait je
dis pas qu'il a fait qu'il était taillé
un grand résistant il l'a fait à la fin
de la guerre trappes qui compte 4300
habitants et détruit aux deux tiers
le bilan est lourd 98 victimes civiles
sont deux prisonniers de guerre et 245
maisons rasées
ça devrait pas exister ligue 1 en
octobre en cours toutes les guerres
qu'il ya maintenant les gens ne sont pas
cons ils ont rien compris et nous
reviendrons bien sûr sur ces
commémorations des témoignages également
dans notre édition de demain vendredi
sur le 6 juin 1944 deux prix décernés ce
mercredi soir par le conseil général des
yvelines et le comité des yvelines de la
ligue contre le cancer le premier existe
depuis 28 ans le second a été lancée en
1974 ils permettent de distinguer
d'encourager des équipes de chercheurs
et qui travaille sur deux nouveaux
modèles de traitement catherine château
et le dis moi
un vaccin contre le cancer un rêve peut
être demain une réalité c'est en tout
cas sur ce principe de vaccins que
travaille depuis 20 ans laurence
zitvogel elles ciblent notamment les
mélanomes les cancers du rein et de
l'ovaire permettent donc d'éduquer des
nouveaux lymphocytes qui vont
reconnaître les cellules tumorales de
façon spécifique
ces vaccins seraient ciblés éviterait
les effets secondaires des traitements
général prescrit dans le cadre des
cancers et permettrait une immunité à
jamais contre les cellules tumorales
chez un patient donné des travaux
aujourd'hui récompensé par un prix de
12500 euros décerné par la ligue contre
le cancer
un autre prix de 10000 euros cette
fois-ci remis par le conseil général a
salué alex duval pour ses travaux sur la
complexité de la tumeur cancéreuse
tumeur qui ne ressemble jamais à une
autre
essayer de démontrer que derrière une
pathologie tumorale comme par exemple le
cancer colorectal qui aujourd'hui est
traité de manière standard chez tous les
patients de la même manière il ya en
fait maladie excessivement complexe qui
est hétérogène avec des groupes de
patients qui ont des tumeurs
particulière qui ont des
caractéristiques génétiques
particulières parce que vous savez que
le cancer est une maladie des gènes et
nous notre travail c'est d'identifier
des sous types de tumeurs
le cancer du côlon ses vingt mille
nouveaux cas par an et un tiers de cette
humeur sont héréditaires c'est dire donc
que l'enjeu est d'importance et dans le
domaine de la recherche tout va
aujourd'hui beaucoup plus vite en ce
moment on a beaucoup de changements dans
notre approche des maladies on a fait
énormément de gains sur la coopération
entre les différentes spécialités qui
déjà en elle-même améliore les résultats
mais la recherche continue à nous amener
de nouvelles propositions de nouvelles
pistes de travail
le prix yvelines de la ligue contre le
cancer est remis depuis 1974
le prix du conseil général et dix
truites depuis m 28 ans un engagement
qui commence à porter ses fruits
elle termine sur une victoire les
féminines du club de tennis de table des
longs cours se sont imposés mardi soir
lors de la dernière
journée du championnat de pro b face à
mulhouse à domicile larges victoires 4
matchs à 1 une victoire qui confirment
leur domination tout au long de la
saison le titre leur est acquis depuis
le mois d'avril première avec au succès
en quatorze rencontres elles vont
découvrir le plus haut niveau français
mais en proie à la compétition effet
relevé on écoute l'entraîneur qui
savoure mais se projette déjà sur la
saison prochaine c'est au micro
d'anthony rage
c'est une belle histoire j'espère
qu'elle va continuer parce qu'on va
partir dans une nouvelle aventure qui
sera pas simple voilà ce que c'est c'est
quand même
un autre milieu un autre niveau et donc
bon il ya aura quelques étapes à
franchir mais on est déjà on va on va
savourer quand même ces petits moments
là il y en aura pas beaucoup on en aura
pas beaucoup dans notre de notre
carrière sportive donc c'était non c'est
chouette c'est vraiment chouette fin du
journal de ce 5 juin je vous retrouve
demain et meurt nous reviendrons
notamment sur les travaux d'extension de
l'hôpital privé de trappes excellente
soirée